hi my name is Dan Shapiro I am a founder
and director of Harvard international
negotiation program and the question I'm
responding to is from swathi Mumbai of
facebook who asks what's the one thing
in 2012 you'd like to see happen in the
world wait come for the place of what is
one of the major problems I see in the
world and its conflicts dealing
constructively and effectively with
conflict in differences I don't think
we're gonna be able to eradicate
conflict I don't think we want to
eradicate conflict the question is how
do we deal with it most effectively it
affects businesses global economies it
affects everyday people's lives in
families as well how do you deal with
conflict there and unlike something like
cancer where a cure is some time away in
the field of conflict management we
already have a lot of the skills we have
a lot of the tools to help people deal
with conflict more effectively so to
answer your question swathi my hope is
that in the year 2012 and beyond we work
to integrate these skills of conflict
management is the school systems into
the governmental systems into the
business systems so that we have a more
effective efficient and thriving world
so thank you all to YouTube look forward
to continued conversation with you